this is how authorities in Bangladesh
responded to protesters on Saturday
thousands of people had turned out
demanding the prime minister's
resignation and calling for a caretaker
Administration to overseas Paul later
this year
on Monday opposition members once again
gathered in the capital DACA to show
their frustration
of opposition members were detained on
Saturday and many were injured including
senior opposition leaders and policemen
[Music]
they've arrested numerous opposition
supporters we had a peaceful Gathering
which was violently attacked by police
and ruling party supporters the
autocratic government snatched out
voting rights also which is why we're
here today
the main opposition Bangladesh
nationalist party and its allies have
been holding anti-government protests
since December last year
Amnesty International has urged the
Bangladeshi authorities to de-escalate
the crisis and respect the rights of
protesters and call for an impartial
investigation into the attack on
opposition leaders
tens of thousands of leaders and
activists of the opposition parties have
gathered here in sarwadi square in the
center of the capital they're here to
protest against police Crackdown on its
members during a sitting program last
Saturday many here believe the last two
general elections were either rigged or
fraudulent but the government remains
defined and rejects any calls for a
neutral interim Administration
we do want an election but they want to
remove Sheikh Hasina from the government
by any means which is their targets if
the voters want us to stay or to go
we'll oblige accordingly we want an
election but it won't help if they keep
getting aggressive about it we are the
government
in recent months Western governments led
by the United States and Rights group
have criticized Sheikh hasina's
Administration for cracking down on
anti-government protests
there is still time to think about this
issue and make arrangement for having
the election under the caretaker
government otherwise we are stating it
clearly that you will not even find any
road to escape
with the troubled economy and a soaring
cost of living Bangladesh now faces the
additional challenge of growing unrest
and calls for a change of government
ahead of general election later this
year tanvi chaudry Al Jazeera Dhaka
foreign